hello welcome to this announcement video
it's a bit of a short notice but I think
are you still going to be happy to learn
that I'm going to play a life blitz
match tonight so it will be a live
stream on my channel a YouTube stream
the link is some in the description of
the video yeah it starts in from this
video post a roughly two hours so it's
a7 p.m. central european time which
makes it what is that that is 1pm us
east coast here so um it's mostly for
the European audience I hope you be able
to join i'm going to play Grand Master
towel Baron not quite sure about the
pronunciation there maybe there's
something I don't know he's very strong
Grandmaster you see speed rating is 2560
so i'll be a bit of an underdog but
let's see what happens we're going to
play up to four points so our best of
the best of eight yeah the first who
reaches for points going to win this so
when we going to see what happens town
control will be five plus two is
somewhat slower blitz time control by
before thought that that gives good
quality games so you just then you have
to click on the link that I'm going to
provide in the description here or just
go to my channel where there's already
this live stream scheduled help you up I
going to join me tonight and also have
the later regular Monday stream so i'll
be streaming two times today okay i hope
you're going to be able to join thank
you